violence against police officers getting
even deadlier the nypd paying tribute
this afternoon after a second officer
has died just days after a suspect shot
him and his partner while both were
responding to a domestic dispute that
comes as a black lives matter chapter
from washington dc faces backlash from
police groups after complaining of
propaganda and saying officers who get
shot should not be called heroes the
group tweeting this look at the reaction
and coverage tonight tearjerker press
conferences and proclamations of heroes
coming soon being black in dc is more
dangerous than any job
first let us all express our condolences
to officer mora and his his family we
really were hoping that he would make it
unfortunately that was not the case so
judge we woke up this morning found out
that the black lives matter chapter in
dc had tweeted that i would imagine that
your
head exploded yeah it's been exploding a
lot in the last month there's been a
police officer shot every day in this
country since the beginning of the year
and we've had four cops shot in new york
city in the past week
most of them are victims of just
ambushes and the bottom line is this
you've got all of these politicians who
now come out and say you know we stand
with the police and all this nonsense
they don't stand with the police because
they were in favor of defunding they're
in favor of eliminating bail
releasing criminals and and lowering
criminal charges and then all of a
sudden because the winds kind of blow in
favor of a police officer they want to
be you know out there with the group
well you know what they ought to put
their money where their mouth is and the
bottom line in this country is until we
start respecting cops until we tell our
children to respect cops nothing is
going to change because these
politicians aren't going to change they
are activists social justice warriors i
never knew what that meant now i know
what it means you know they talk about
white privilege this is criminal
privilege criminals have all the
privilege and you've got black lives
matter the organization not the movement
i want to be really clear if they care
about what their title alleges then they
would want to be in the inner cities
where most of the victims of crime are
african-americans and brown children
that's why you've got eric adams saying
i'm going to start
bringing in street crime units again i'm
going to start focusing on where these
kids are if you really care about black
children then get involved in mentoring
put some kind of after-school program in
give them an internship make believe you
care for the black lives that are being
lost these are just just just money
hucksters who are doing nothing but
promoting division in this country how
are you greg
well done well said uh yeah
it's not that surprising because you
have to understand there is an
underlying
streak in blm that is anti-cop
it is there they happen to sucker the
media into thinking it was something
else and so the media treated them with
an exalted reverence even as police were
getting shot you actually couldn't say
anything if you said blue lives matter
or all lives matter somehow that was an
attack on blm and you were racist the
media embraced a narrative that
contributed to a nationwide ferguson
effect right devaluing of police and
ultimately a crime wave in the crumbling
of cities run by liberals so where do
you think the smashing grabs the random
murders the carjackings the gang
violence comes from it was an acceptance
of an idea that america was hopelessly
corrupt and therefore looting and arson
were seen as justifiable behavior that
opened the doors to uh progressive
nightmares like no cash bail early
release of violent felons defunding of
police early retirement of cops all of
this came from the same mentality and it
is a underlying anti-police streak that
has been a part of activism for decades
geraldo you are
um expressing some i i i was deeply
touched by the judge's uh recitation
just then i i was
it was slammed there was a slam in my
heart when uh jason rivera
the first cop the 22 year old was dead
on the scene
and maura was clinging to life it just
you could weep it was so so
horrible and and and just to
continue this whole idea of how cops
they have been uh pilloried uh the riots
uh the george floyd riots where they
were they were
the molontov cocktails and assaulted and
every crap you could think of thrown at
them
uh and still they they held the thin
blue line the thin blue line separating
civilization from anarchy but i tell you
that thing about propaganda in dc from
that blm chapter
being black is more dangerous than any
job he's right
d.c had 227 murders
last year vast majority of them almost
all of them black
including 33 women and children
where was black lives matter where was
black lives matter the black lives
really matter or the black lives only
matter when a cop is involved
227 murders what the blm what did that
big mouth
do about the 227
mostly black people were murdered in dc
by mostly black people what did you do
you did nothing
you did nothing
jesse last word i would just say that
police officers are almost always
saving black lives from black on black
crime and that needs to be acknowledged
it was a bait and switch blm it started
off as a nice movement trump bought into
it remember the george floyd he said it
was terrible everyone thought so
corporate america bought into it then
what happened then they started burning
everything and then the people that were
leading this thing started looting it
and buying luxury spreads in california
and the caribbean
and then we get all these statements
from these like sounds like communist
revolutionaries and they say oh no no
that was just a chapter that was
unaffiliated with the national
organization that happened ten times you
start thinking like oh my god this isn't
what they said it was and i always look
at these
movements for their results
where the results you didn't get police
reform you got a lot of property damage
you defunded the police and it cost a
lot of black lives and now the brand has
sunk to below 50 approval and now
everyone's thinking oh my god what have
we gotten ourselves involved in hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else